hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up
British steel announces it's closing its
coking ovens resulting in the loss of
260 jobs the company says it's trying to
become clean and green
[Music]
the government's green heating plan is
seriously failing according to a House
of Lords climate committee
and Cyclone Freddy is lashing Madagascar
just weeks after another tropical storm
killed 33 people worth
foreign
to the Daily climate show where we track
the changes to our world and investigate
some of the potential solutions to The
Climate crisis now British Stills
announced it will cut up to 260 jobs at
its scunthorpe plants as part of its
drive to build a green and sustainable
future the Chinese owned steel maker
says it will close one of its Coke Ovens
citing Rising energy costs and the need
to improve its environmental performance
well let's cross straight over and
joining me now is our business presenter
Ian King Ian tell us more about this
announcement well it's very interesting
Simon that British steel which is owned
by the Chinese company jinyi it's made
very clear that this is all part of its
decarbonization plan for its site at
scunthorpe one of four sites it has
across the UK is going to be closing
those two coking ovens as you say with
the potential loss of up to 260 jobs but
really the background to this is that
both the jingy and tartar steel which is
the bigger of the main steel makers in
this country have been in talks with the
government for months about a support
package enabling them to decarbonize the
steel industry the government is
effectively looking to reduce carbon
emissions in the UK steel industry by 95
between now and 2050 and Central to that
is getting the steel makers to switch to
lower carbon intensive uh electric Arc
furnaces and that is uh what jingyi the
owner of British steel has been gunning
for in the meantime though the company
has seen its energy bill Rise by 120
million pounds during the last 12 months
and its uh raw materials cost by a
further 90 million pounds and that the
company says has rendered these coking
ovens on economic and bear in mind these
uh assets are approaching the end of
their natural working life in any case
the company stressing that it's invested
some 330 million pounds already in its
three years of ownership the unite Union
which is represented the plant says that
this has not been enough and that the
company has not lived up to the promises
that it made when it bought British
still the renamed British steel back in
2020 so uh both sides really at
loggerheads decarbonization is at the
heart of this story though I don't think
that will come as much comfort to the
workers who potentially look like being
rendered unemployed as a result of this
announcement
live from the city thanks very much
right let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news for you now and
Europe's carbon price has hit a record
100 euros per ton a milestone that
boosts the case for companies to find
Greener Alternatives to fossil fuels
well carbon pricing is a cost applied to
the amount of carbon pollution emitted
by an organization putting a price on
carbon incentivizes companies to cut the
use of fossil fuels
comedian Frankie Boyle is among a group
of activists urging prime minister Rishi
sunak to throw out plans to develop a
new oil and gas field in the North Sea
well the group are urging the government
to block the proposed Rose Bank oil
field off Shetland energy Minister Grant
shafts is expected to decide on whether
to approve the project imminently Mr
ball says the plan makes no sense as the
world faces a climate emergency
the mother of Ella advocacy Deborah the
London school girl who became the first
person in Britain to have air pollution
listed as a cause of death says there's
still a long way to go in improving the
capital's air quality her mother
Rosamund has been campaigning for
cleaner air since her daughter's death
and is calling on MPS to support her
cleaner Human Rights bill known as
Ella's law the bill is due for a second
reading in the Commons on Friday
LS law will enshrine everybody's right
to clean air into law explicitly yeah
that is what it it will do every time
there's a major decision like a
developmental thing they will have to
look at the air pollution and also we're
heading to 2020 the whole world is going
to be electrified and this is just a
start so air pollution is a huge problem
yes it has got better but there is still
a long way to go
the United States are bracing four
record snowfall ahead of a massive
winter storm the national weather
service has issued warnings for
dangerously cold temperatures blizzards
and high wind advisories for large parts
of the western and Central areas of the
United States experts say the growing
frequency and intensity of such storms
are symptoms of climate change
now a 450 million pound government
scheme to encourage households to
upgrade gas boilers to low carbon
Alternatives is failing that's according
to a House of Lords committee the
program gives out 5 000 pound grants to
help people install heat pumps in their
homes as part of the efforts to meet the
UK's Net Zero goals but the environment
and climate change committee says just a
third of the annual budget has been used
since May and is calling for Urgent
changes to the scheme well the chair of
that committee baroness palminter joins
me now from Westminster good afternoon
to you
um
what's going on here why is this scheme
not working
looks really disappointing results for
the first year of the boiler upgrade
scheme we know that 17 of our greenhouse
gases here in the UK come from our home
so we've got to get on and get on fast
changing our heating systems the
majority as you rightly set at gas are
moving them over to low carbon heatings
and heat pumps are a mature technology
which we need to move to but the trouble
is the government scheme has been beset
by problems very few people know about
the fact that they need to change their
home heating systems the government's
own figures say it's 62 percent of
people is the total number of people who
think that they know what they want to
do with their homes to turn them to low
carbon and only eight and there's a
staggering eighty percent who don't know
anything about heat pumps which are the
best low carb and Home Heating solution
so awareness is a really big problem
that's beset the scheme in its first
year
so so what changes would you like to see
is it is it simply an awareness campaign
I mean as I understand it there aren't
even enough people to install these heat
pumps
absolutely awareness is part of the
problem and the government's got to
invest in a public awareness campaign on
low carb and heating but you're right
there aren't anywhere near enough
installers if you wanted to go out and
say great I'm going to get a heat pump
you go on the government dot UK website
and you might find that in the nearest
installer is 100 miles away there's only
3 000 estimated heat pump installers in
the UK at the moment and yet the
government themselves say they're going
to need uh nearly 12 000 heat pump
installers by 2025. and of course
hydrogen is also considered a potential
alternative so tell us about that and
the government's uh switch to Renewables
well we're particularly concerned on our
committee at the moment the government
is sending out mixed messages to people
about the role of hydrogen in Home
Heating in the short to medium term
we're very clear that hydrogen doesn't
play a role and shouldn't play a role in
Home Heating in the short to medium term
we don't know how we're going to be able
to produce enough green hydrogen in the
future for some of the really hard to
treat Industries like steel so in the
home heating area we think the
government should be prioritizing mature
technology which is used very well on
Mainland Europe but the government set
itself some ambitious Net Zero targets
unless it amends this boiler upgrade
scheme and addresses some of the flaws
in this first year there's absolutely no
way it's going to achieve its targets
okay baroness palminter thanks very much
indeed for joining us on the daily
climate show
now in a response to that report the
government said it's launching a
marketing campaign to increase public
awareness of the fund
now to Madagascar where a deadly
tropical Cyclone has made landfall with
gusts of up to 110 miles per hour and
widespread flooding the Cyclone has
displaced more than 16
000 people just a month after another
storm killed 33 people on the island
well earlier I spoke to Tropical Cyclone
expert and Claire Fontan and I began by
asking her what impact climate change
has had on extreme weather it's tropical
Cyclone season right now so of course
you will have tropical Cyclones now what
is uh from last year's studies as you
may remember Madagascar has been hit by
five Cyclones within six weeks between
late January to February 2022 and there
were some studies made about that and
there is a fact that
associated with tropical Cyclones due to
climate change there is no highest rate
of rainfall associated with these
tropical Cyclones so this is basically
what we can attribute to climate change
is that in the future those tropical
Cyclones will be associated with
heaviest amount of rain
and briefly how all countries across
Southeast Africa adapting to these
changing circumstances and climate
so I would like to say that uh for for
free tropical recycled Freddie uh some
lessons have been learned from last year
with tropical Cyclone byzier high and
early action has been taken this year so
that massive evacuation occurred ahead
of the event to evacuate people far away
from the coast so he has reduced uh the
mitigate the loss right so what is
important here is that
the warning uh reaching triggering the
right action reach the people and and
that's why wmo is now Spar heading the
United Nation early warning for all
initiatives now a top priority to ensure
that everyone is covered by the warnings
by early warnings uh in the next five
years and Claire Fontaine tropical
Cyclone expert thanks very much indeed
for speaking to the Daily climate show
and we were of course talking about that
Cyclone striking Madagascar Gus of up to
110 miles per hour and of course
Southeast Africa prone to Cyclones now
and scientists saying that it is proof
that climate change is impacting the
Southeastern Africa region
now just a reminder that you can watch
Tom Heap descend into London's new super
sewer this week that's on Saturday and
Sunday at 3 30 in the afternoon right
here on Sky News
and before we go we want your climate
questions anything that's ever mystified
you about the environment or whatever
you want to get to the bottom of scan
the QR code on your screen right now and
send us your questions and we'll try and
have them answered in the climate Show
with Tom Heap
and if you scan this QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to this
week's edition of the climate cast
subscribe now wherever you get your
podcast from
that's it from me thanks for watching
that's all from us for today join us
again on the daily climate show same
time tomorrow 3 30 P.M